una investigación independiente de la
onu concluyó el viernes que fueron las
fuerzas israelíes y no los militantes
palestinos quienes efectuaron el disparo
que mató al sur y nawa clay una
periodista de al yazira que fue
asesinada mientras cubría una incursión
del ejército israelí en jenín en
cisjordania ocupada
audi y toda la información que hemos
reunido incluida la documentación
oficial del ejército israelí y del
fiscal general palestino es coherente
con la conclusión de que los disparos
que mataron a abu a clay e hirieron a su
colega procedieron de las fuerzas de
seguridad israelíes y no de disparos
indiscriminados de palestinos armados
como afirmaron inicialmente las
autoridades israelíes
la onu añadió que la ausencia de una
investigación penal por parte de israel
es profundamente preocupante
la periodista de 51 años era una
reconocida corresponsable en la región y
miles de personas asistieron a su
funeral en jerusalén este las fuerzas de
defensa de israel emitieron un
comunicado en respuesta a la onu
insistiendo en que se había producido un
intercambio de disparos entre sus
fuerzas y hombres armados palestinos y
que no se podía determinar el
responsable la investigación de las
fuerzas israelíes concluye claramente
que la señora bachelet no fue baleada
intencionalmente por un soldado de las
fuerzas de defensa israelíes y que no es
posible determinar si fue asesinada por
un pistolero palestino que disparó
indiscriminadamente en su zona o
inadvertidamente por un soldado de las
fuerzas de defensa israelíes aunque
israel se ha ofrecido a realizar un
análisis balístico en caso de que los
palestinos entre en la bala que acabó
con la vida de agua que las autoridades
palestinas rechazaron la semana pasada
esta oferta alegando falta de confianza
al yazira anunció el mes pasado que
había asignado un equipo jurídico para
llevar el caso a la corte penal
internacional